Next, we prove that
this reduction works.
Let f be a 3CNF formula with
n variables and m clauses.
And we'll let A and
k be the result of the transformation.
First, we show that if f is satisfiable,
then there's a subset of A summing to k.
Let t be the satisfying assignment.
Then we include yi in our set S,
if xi is true under the truth
assignment, and we include zi otherwise.
As for the g and h families,
if fewer than three literals of
a clause are satisfied, then include g.
If fewer than 2, then include h as well.
In total, the sum of these
numbers must be equal to k.
In the other direction, we argue that
if there is a subset of A summing to k,
then there's a satisfying assignment.
Suppose that S is a subset
of A summing to k.
Then the impossibility of
carrying the digits in any sum
implies that exactly one of yi or
zi must have been set to true.
Therefore, we can define a truth
assignment, t where t of xi is true
if yi is included, and
it's false otherwise.
This must satisfy every clause,
otherwise there would be no way that the
total in the clause places could be 3.
All together,
we've seen that subset-Si, is an NP.
And we can reduce 3-CNFSAT,
an NP-complete problem to it.
So Subset-Sum must be NP-complete.